this is what conservatives get wrong
conservatives are thinking that the
enemy or the labor party or the
democrats here and we're going to kick
joe biden out of office or we're going
to be jeremy corbyn blah blah that's not
the issue jeremy corbyn is the tail joe
biden is the tail the corporate press
are the dog who are wagging that tail
michael mallis welcome to the show
thank you so much chris
how are you are you missing me
enormously i text you all the time turn
it back yes well i'm back this week
you'll have me this week
that's phenomenal can't get rid of me
and i'm going to see jordan john
peterson over in san antonio what's san
antonio like i've never been
it's very corporate it's it's um it
almost feels like an 80s movie because
there's all these tall buildings there's
one cool little river that runs through
the city which is fun to kind of the
river walk but other than that it's a
very much a concrete
kind of edifice and san antonio has a
much bigger population in my
understanding than austin but there
seems to be a bit of a um
soullessness to it yeah that's kind of
what i got from the outside that it's um
it's definitely a bigger sort of
downtown area than austin boston's so
distributed we went for a walk
through the burbs of austin for two
hours and you realize that the stretches
on and on and on and on yeah
that's crazy have you been keeping up to
date with the canadian truckers protest
thing
oh yes
not as much as other people but most
certainly the honking will continue
until freedom improves
so yeah i had this um
chapter in my book than you write that
says me magic is real
and i'm sure most people listening uh
have seen on social media
that uh you know in the last year or
more certainly there's been this meme of
clown world where people say something
that's perfectly ridiculous and they're
responded to with uh you know a green
clown
pressing his nose or there's another
meme where it's a lobster claw holding a
clown nose saying here you drop this
so that had been a thing and now
literally they're literally honking
and there's people on reddit having
meltdowns uh saying like i can't sleep
this is terrorism yep uh and and you're
exactly right the honking will continue
and the thing that's i've made this
point several times and i'll make it
again here uh especially with the
british audience
that um there is a misconception by
conservatives and i mean american
conservatives i don't know about uh tory
conservatives in the uk but that you
know
you know in america especially there's
different groups
that the progressives latch on to to
further their agenda it's muslim
immigrants it's transgender bathrooms
one month or whatever so on and so forth
and the point i always beat into their
heads is they don't really care about
these groups this is just whoever is a
useful tool at the moment and as soon as
that group is defiant in any way
they're thrown into the rubbish bin as
you'd say and the best example of this
is you know here we have the center-left
parties the democrats obviously there
you guys have the labor party but as
soon as labor starts being defiant all
of a sudden they're nazis and it's just
a fascinating phenomenon to see and i
think it's just completely transparent
how your measure or virtue as an
interest group
is directly correlated to how useful you
are to furthering a certain agenda dude
that's so nailed it like it but it's
one thing
isn't that also what
uh broke down the so-called red wall in
the last election that these districts
that had been uh read labor's read is uh
more correctly than here we have here
read is labor uh over in the uk these
were labor districts for i think almost
a century that went blue yeah and places
like hartlepool and blyth that are both
near me and where i've grown up they are
labor strongholds pit village my
granddaddy was a miner and he hated
thatcher and my daddy was a miner and he
hated thatcher
that ran on for a long time and then you
know the left appears to be
very much a sort of bourgeois foe
intellectual
this sort of middle class looking down
on the underclass and the working class
movement at the moment and you're right
it's whoever's convenient this is what
bridget said the other day but she was
actually taking the shot
uh from a different angle talking about
people that are on the right who are
saying we care about women's rights
because of these uh trans people that
are encroaching on them she's like you
don't care about [ __ ] women's rights
yeah right you're correct
you don't care about them at all it most
certainly goes both ways yeah it's just
like there's a certain
but there's a certain irony in calling
yourself labor
and then telling people that the unions
are nazis what is it in canada what's
the have you got any idea liberals right
so they have the the liberals uh which
is the center left party they have the
conservatives which is fairly recent
because the progressive conservatives
had imploded in the 90s and then they
have a party to the left which is what
they're the new democrats i think
they're called yeah and they're so those
are like what's that the ndp yeah
um
so they're the real like hard leftists
or there's and there's also the green
party of course the trudeau has
disappeared like saddam did you see that
he's like freaking out
my understanding was he was on u.s soil
maybe
yeah i said that he should be if he's on
u.s soil they should send him to gitmo
but let's let's not forget that he has
covered so one of the problems that
they've got at the moment is that
truckers 90 of whom are vaccinated
aren't
agreeing to a vaccine mandate about
crossing the border because presumably
america is concerned about people with
covet crossing the border and trudeau a
man who has covered has potentially fled
canada
uh due to security concerns about this
trucker's protest
into the us
well in his defense if you've got a
convoy full of nazi truckers as a black
man he's going to have to kind of
do a reverse underground railroad
because they'll see his skin and they'll
judge him accordingly
yeah they got accused everything
happened right first off it was that
they were
actually everyone seemed to be kind of
behind it you know it's a peaceful
protest very polite and then as it
picked up speed and do you realize that
the mainstream media was just going to
start throwing every ism and east that
they could first they said that they
they lied there was the
canadian news outlet um
that's from new brunswick i think it was
where they're saying that uh they're
protesting their working conditions
so they just completely lied about what
they were protesting um then a couple of
days ago gofundme as i'm sure people saw
just decided to seize
all the money and said we're going to
send it wherever we want and that was a
huge backlash and they had they actually
refunded instead of seizing it oh is
that has that happened because i thought
that they seized it and said they were
giving it to particular
worthy no no it's been it's been
resolved it's because because they have
something called i think the issue was
if i i double check me because this is
kind of you see things on twitter it's
kind of like plato's cave but my
understanding was your people are going
to call and ask for chargebacks and when
that happens they're hit for each one
with like a 15 fee but also the public
shaming was enormous and i know some
politicians got involved
you don't get simply to just oh you know
i'm contributing to the trucker as well
that's null and voice so this is going
to go to you know
we want yeah yeah there's a quote here
organizers provided a clear distribution
plan for the initial 1 million this is
from gofundme's
uh statement that was released earlier
this week and confirmed funds would be
used only for participants who travel to
ottawa to participate in a peaceful
protest given how the situation has
evolved no further funds will be
directly distributed to the freedom
convoy organizers we will work with
organizers to send all remaining funds
to credible and established charities
verified by gofundme all donors may
submit a request for a full refund until
february 19th so that was they were
giving people two weeks
to get on and order a refund but it
seems now because of the backlash that
they've just done all of it which i mean
it's strange that that somehow feels
like a victory
because the anchoring point has been set
so oh at least they didn't steal it and
give it to another charity well no they
shut it down and didn't give it to the
people it was supposed to go to
i would just i would say the victory
here
is that their machinations are made
public
because this permanently establishes the
brand as ideologically driven
um it would be one thing if they had
said disingenuously
that we're not giving this to the convoy
because it's the convoy is being run by
white supremacists and we stand against
white supremacists it would be a brazen
lie but that would be something that
would make sense this is just they said
well it's not organized it's no longer
classified uh by whom as a peaceful
protest is classified as an insurrection
therefore we can't take part in
insurrection great send the money back
um but i i think this is a very healthy
and necessary
step forward in our cultural bifurcation
and there's one it's what's really funny
is there's an enormous movement that's
insisting that everyone takes sides and
this has been going on at least since
2015 and the sides are the good guys or
the nazis
and then there's plenty of people who
are saying
screw you i'm not with you and they
don't but we said if you don't side with
us you're nazis like cool story bro um
and
therefore they're forcing people to view
things
uh as in group and out group and that's
causing the out group to form
alternative mechanisms and then they're
pulling their hair out it's like how
dare you
you're supposed to be in our group as
subordinates so this isn't something
that's going to happen increasingly and
it's something that needs to happen uh
and the idea that there's one agency
whoever it is who gets to define
you know these riots are peaceful
and you know these truckers are
insurrectionists
uh and you know it's very clear
how the cards are going to fall i'm
shocked
to how quickly
people have grown
wise to how the game is played because
you don't have to have any opinion on
canada or the truckers or really go fund
me
to know how this movie plays out
is it not more hatred of the working
class again though look at these idiot
uneducated truckers that don't know
what's best for them don't worry you
should be listening to us the people who
are actually in positions of power the
ones that are educated enough to make
decisions about you you know it was okay
for you to have your little protest for
a while but when it starts to perhaps
make genuine change
we are a lot less happy about that and
you think well hang on these the
working class that you're supposed to
represent they're telling you like
they're literally telling you people
aren't deciding to go out into the
middle of the canadian winter and it
looks [ __ ] miserable it looks so
miserable while whatever it is that
they're doing and people are setting up
pizza ovens and soup kitchens and
they're standing guard around a statue
of a one-legged man because it got
desecrated a couple of days ago they're
not doing that because they're bored but
that takes an awful lot of effort to go
and do something like that so this is
the working class telling you what they
feel
so no they're not so the argument is
they've all been brainwashed
by the forces of evil
somehow trump's probably involved so
they don't really recognize them as
having agency
when they're being defiant
and the issue with defiance is
now the entire population which had been
docile and submissive because they were
told and reiterated that they have no
choice that we have to make these hard
decisions in order to save everyone's
lives now to have a large group of
people say
hold on a minute
there are other ways to go about this
this causes people who prefer safety to
liberty enormous psychological distress
because everything in their mental
makeup is about um giving up
choice and
having options in favor of being told
what to do for the sake of security and
safety which has not at all been
guaranteed to them whatsoever but they
can act as if it has been there's a guy
who called into a show that i listened
to saying that he hasn't had sleep in
nearly five days now because of this
honking and that's the other side of it
where you go okay like that bit does
suck i've been kept awake by loud noises
previously when i've been in cities and
it
really is quite bad
i don't really know what you're supposed
to do about that i i don't believe him
it's not because of the honking it's
because of his neurosis so what kovitt
did very effectively was to allow
highly educated
uh urban people which tend to correlate
very well with
mental illness such as anxiety and
depression and other sorts of neurosis
this gives them an external source to
blame for their issues so instead of you
know i'm suffering because you know of
me i'm suffering because everyone's
suffering uh so you if you just because
there is a cause
for something that does not mean that
the response is proportional or a direct
uh direct result of that cause uh i
don't believe it's not possible that
sure i i'll believe him that for five
nights his sleep was poor but you know
it go i i have very little sympathy for
him yeah and the thing is it's very
important you also remember that in this
kind of culture
being a victim is a high status marker
so the more you demonstrate that you
personally are suffering as a
consequence of bad people the more
virtuous they're accordingly you can
claim yourself to be i read a study the
other day about people who are open
about past lives of victimhood uh on
dating profiles and how people respond
to that so a lot of the time typically
people are positively inclined to the
zero to hero story
and we see this get manipulated with um
training plans right here's a before
person oh yeah out of shape and he's an
imperson that's in shape and yes you
know those are the sort of instagram
posts to get loads of likes um
interestingly on dating apps somebody
that puts i used to be a victim but now
i have
overcome my past traumas and i am better
or whatever uh that doesn't get that is
negatively correlated with likes on uh
dating apps so there is something in
there
maybe there's a still a sense of sort of
the cursed child type thing the fact
that something that was wrong with you
in the past is
it's almost like a a biological concern
about somebody that was maybe diseased
that's how rob henderson put it across
that perhaps there's something that we
concern this may come back there's
something icky as well that people have
in response and i've seen this happen
online with somebody that opens up about
depression no matter how
open the conversation about mental
health gets there's still always a
little bit of just
ick that sometimes happens that i see
from people in their responses when
others open up about it
don't you think it's because depression
is i'm using this word very loosely
contagious
like when we're around depressed people
it does not it's it's draining
is victimhood the same past victimhood
i've overcome my traumas i think on
dating apps
and i'm completely talking out of my ass
but there might be a gender issue right
so if it's a man who the first thing he
says is how he was victimized i think
women might be perceiving him as weak
and if a woman is talking about how she
was a victim men who already are
predisposed to this are going to
perceive her as either high maintenance
or cra or crazy
and this is really but at the same time
i feel like you know someone who has had
past trauma and i've talked about this
on rogan in other episodes
that's quite an icebreaker
uh and i think there that is that is
still correctly
kind of a social taboo if this is
something you if i meet you
at a bar or a party and this is one of
the first things you tell me in five
minutes
that's gonna tell me wait a minute
something is wrong here that is
something if i got to know you more
intimately even just slightly into me
like an hour into a conversation oh you
know as a kid you know i grew up with an
alcoholic mom
then oh okay you know that's fine but if
this is front and center why is it
important for you to be telling me this
that's right up front dude that's really
smart so
what you're saying uh the fact that you
have labeled yourself as it undermines
the fact that you say you've transcended
it yeah
yeah that's that's a really [ __ ] good
insight i'm gonna send that to rob how
closely are you following this russia
and ukraine situation of you were
you grew up in love right i grew up in
brooklyn i was born there
born in lavov
yeah are you keeping your eyes on this
no very little i am what the one thing i
have noticed
um is
it's i'm very disturbed by of course the
war drums uh you know uh putin's no joke
russia's no joke and
the ukrainian president
from my understanding went on the air
and said
the media is blowing us out of
proportion things are not getting
demonstrably worse uh calm the hell down
so and i also think if there's something
anathema
at least in american media about seeing
things from other countries perspectives
because we're the good guys and whatever
we do is right and they're the bad guys
and or the weak and uh suck it up and if
you are going to go to any country
and put troops on the foreign troops on
the border to expect that other country
to just kind of be like oh it's america
they're the good guys but you know this
is fine it is bonkers
same with british troops you know what i
mean you're going to get british troops
in in you know on the border india the
indians are going like hold on a minute
we've been through this before what do
you think's going to happen roll the
clock forward
um
i i'm sure
that there there always is in the us and
you know
very notoriously this is the only quote
from eisenhower that people know you
know he warned about the
military-industrial complex there is an
enormous amount of profit
to be made and a lot of power to be
gained when a nation is at war it does
well for the president in terms of
approval ratings uh the nation rallies
around and in times of conflict uh they
get to go to the funerals and look at
heroes
with all these coffins that didn't need
to be there um you get to kind of seem
strong
so there is an enormous incentive
um you know for washington to have war
and in case people think oh you're
talking crazy keep in mind that last
summer we killed a bunch of kids
in afghanistan and not only did no one
apologize no one was even fired for it
so
human life means absolutely nothing
to the federal government and if it can
be leveraged anyway to further the
government's agenda they'll be happy to
do so um i think putin sees biden as
weak
certainly biden is in a weak position
given a 50 50 senate given a five-seat
majority in the house which is 435
members total um
i i
i i don't know what's going to happen i
am concerned
but i'm most concerned
that there is an enormous incentive
among american media and american
politics to make this a bigger deal
than it is
so it could be something like you know
they take some town which is not
acceptable and ukraine and putin would
prefer to be like all right pay us off
you get the town or something like that
and the us insinuates itself goes no no
no
nato we're going to protect borders blah
blah blah so it's very easy to imagine a
situation
where the americans make it infinitely
worse and boris is also embroiled now as
well
i i don't think he's long for this world
i don't see how he survives this you
think
well i mean isn't it aren't all the tour
i mean theresa may my god talk about a
guy
talk about a vampire rising from the
grave she went up on that floor and she
nuked him i mean she's been a lady
macbeth she's been holding that lady
make beth she's been holding that knife
for a long time
and she got him good so i know as a lady
who had to go i know when it is time to
go
she said that yeah
no she didn't yeah yeah yeah i didn't
see that clip i just saw him she's like
which is it did you not believe in these
rules or did you believe in them and not
care about them i was like holy crap
she's right there's a bit where she said
as someone who had to go i know when it
is time to go holy crap
but the thing is he had four ministers
quit uh it's just no idea enough man
there's not gonna be i don't think that
the only way that this is going to
happen is if the next general election
looks like he is too toxic to get the
conservatives across the line and that
seems unlikely given the fact that they
just had the biggest landslide victory
in
labor is now seven points ahead in all
polls
so if you look at uh wikipedia has
opinion polling for the next uk general
election you can see that it's a giant x
so you had a big line conservative labor
then they tied and now cirque here is
way ahead in every single poll
so you know the same thing with thatcher
the you know the reason thatcher got
kicked out by her own party people in
america couldn't grab their heads around
it is because by that point for one of
the reasons by that point in the polls
like labor was shellacking them and any
politician is going to look out for his
own seat or her own seat first and
foremost and also in all fairness it's
embarrassing if i'm a tory you know
minister or tory backbencher for me to
campaign to put boris johnson back in
number 10 it's like whoa whoa i couldn't
see my mom at her funeral he's having
keggers and whatever jin i don't know
pims uh at number 10 and i'm supposed to
vote for you and
i would feel humiliated yeah
because it was so gratuitous
that's i don't know i it really does i
don't know whether it's a flaw in the
the current system and this probably
plays into your hands quite nicely
that so much of an entire party hinges
around one particular individual at the
top
the fact that boris
doing something which yeah is a prick
thing to do but it's something that your
[ __ ] next door neighbor could have
done it's not actually to do with his
deployment of his duties it's to do with
the way that people perceive his
personality the way that he conducts
himself
yes it was on government property that
he was having these parties but also
it's not really it wasn't like he was
lying to the [ __ ] house of lords or
some [ __ ] um
it feels like a weakness because
obviously within the system attacking
that person and making degrading their
particular value
has a cascading outsized effect across
however many hundreds of different
constituencies there are
yeah that was a result of the later
thatcher years when she very much made
it much more of a presidential model
uh than a parliamentary parliamentary
model
like all her original people kind of
kind of left she was left left with like
kind of second tier
nobodies who were only there by virtue
of her personality uh she was very much
the face of the british government
whereas previously it was much more you
know you had the home minister home
secretary you had the labor education
secretary whatever they were and they
kind of took questions and very much
manage their own portfolios which is why
you have a government which would have
you know some uh people who are
secretaries are more conservative some
were liberal in both parties but with
her when she became this kind of big
international force it really and tony
blair did this as well um it very much
became
you know
that person becomes the face of her
majesty's government especially
internationally um and
it was a big sea change
in in uk politics and it also doesn't
hurt when boris does have such a big
you know flamboyant appearance and
flamboyant personality uh this was an
issue in terms of him uh getting in you
know was he going to be able to give
theresa may run for her money he chose
not to run at the time but you know this
is when you have someone who's kind of
this
either uh
large in life personality or if you
don't like him a buffoon you know this
becomes and this was also an issue for
corbin because you know the the issue
the question was do you want to put
jeremy corbyn
in number 10. it very much nationalized
and personalized the last election and
thankfully the the british voters
resoundingly said no well a lot of the
time people don't vote for parties they
vote for people and it's that cultive
personality thing yeah it's just the way
it is finishing off that what we were
talking about to do with russia i'd
pulled this piece out that just the
language that's used when you were
talking about um escalating or
increasing exaggerating the sense of
um
vociferousness
in the situation international
diplomatic efforts going on amidst
military tension between russia and
ukraine diplomatic efforts continued on
tuesdays u.s secretary of state anthony
blinken spoke with the russian
foreign prime minister and the british
prime minister they had a discussion
with the ukrainian president emphasized
that further invasion of ukraine would
be met with swift and severe
consequences and urged russia to pursue
a diplomatic path according to a u.s
state department
statement the ukraine prime minister
said he hopes the country will be able
to launch a new regional format of
cooperation ukraine poland uk and that
in context of ongoing russian aggression
we should sign a trilateral document on
cooperation to strengthen regional
security the russian president on
tuesday said the western powers are
ignoring moscow's security concerns and
using russia as a tool to contain russia
using ukraine as a tool to contain
russia
yeah so look at it from putin's point of
view right which is oh my god how can
you say that
like i'm against ukraine you know we've
had
let's say rivalry to put it mildly for
centuries and now ukraine's calling in
britain for backup and they're they're
not only saying this just theoretically
we're going to sign a treaty that if
anything happens you've got the entire
force of the uk that are going to be on
the border with with russia of course
putin's not going to like this now you
could it's kind of who started it but at
a certain point if you're going to talk
diplomacy you have to recognize both
parties have legitimate concerns neither
one is de-escalating the situation
right if he's putting troops on the
border and you're responding with
ukrainian troops and here come the brits
and the americans aren't far behind you
know sure he's gonna back down what then
you have to wonder wait a minute if i'm
gonna back down here what's going to
stop you guys from further you know
pushing your luck uh in terms of areas
that historically may have not belonged
to russia um
what were your thoughts on the whoopi
goldberg fallout this week
uh i didn't
i thought she whoopi goldberg is a
phyllo semite i did a project with her
she's very pro jewish uh in her personal
life um she's not an anti-semite at all
it's crazy i think she was just saying
something
kind of awkwardly meaning the holocaust
wasn't and again i could i could be
putting words in my mouth maybe i'm
being too generous my interpretation of
her comments but i thought she was
saying the holocaust isn't about race
when she said it's about man's and
humanity man this is a much bigger issue
than mere racism this is something that
is primal and central to understanding
of human nature and i don't understand
what suspending her for two weeks
accomplishes i this of course genocide
is an issue that should be treated
carefully when we talk about murdering
children it's not the same as discussing
tax rates uh or you know what kind of
hard boy legs we should have for
breakfast or whether those are healthy
or not but i think she was speaking in
good faith
um i think she got left out to drive my
understanding because she did what abc
told her to do to go out and apologize
and they still punched her after it for
which my understanding the reports are
saying uh she was furious whoopi is even
though she's hard left often an
unorthodox thinker she spoke out how she
defended george w bush in terms of
immigration she's against the uh death
tax which we have here um so and she's
often
i think i've seen i think speak to
hannity i know she's spoken with
hardcore conservatives who other people
regard as radioactive so
i i don't see what
the suspending her will gain
um except just make the issue
radioactive as opposed to an issue that
should be treated with decorum i don't
think that her apology on the night time
did her very many favors she sort of
entered it and it was okay and then by
the end of it she she didn't really
actually apologize she basically said
i'm sorry if you misinterpreted what i
said which is just the shittiest [ __ ]
way to do an apology sure ever like that
was really poorly played but i also
agree i i think that
it didn't seem to me like she was trying
to
like she had a lack of sympathy
particularly for that it was just very
very poorly worded and
it's the [ __ ] view
like this is supposed to get you ready
for picking the k drop you've dropped
the kids off at school and you come back
and you why is this even a topic for
them to discuss
well they do they have because they have
these issues all the time but
i mean you if you suspended everyone
from the view when they had a poorly
thought out poorly articulated opinion
you wouldn't have a show
i mean this is the show where
sharon osborne
cancelled from the show for defending
piers morgan that's the talk
oh the talk was a rip-off show of the
view it's basically the identical show
and she was yeah she got cancelled for
for saying you know pierce might have a
point that meghan markle might be a
sociopath which her own family
bear you in mind had said now it which
is just so insane that the other thing
about that's great about the view side
note
is uh megan mccain has a pathological
hatred of the british and it comes out
whenever these topics come out so there
had been issues where they were talking
about like prince harry and she's like
my great-grandparents didn't fight the
redcoats for me to sit here and care
about the effing british and screw them
i don't have an opinion and she just
goes on these bizarre rants whenever the
uk uh royal family comes up it's just
beautiful well i'm talking i'm talking
to megan mccain she's got a new book out
soon i'm talking to a publisher about
bringing her on but now i've got second
thoughts about that
[Laughter]
i'll dm her right now and tell her
[ __ ] hell yeah man i just
there feels like there's a thread
between all of the things that we've
seen at the moment whether it be the
rugged situation the trucker situation
the whoopi goldberg situation everything
is at maximum volume the whole time and
what everyone is searching for
is
this is the tip of the iceberg
that shows us the remainder of your
reprehensible personality this one thing
was a slip up that you did that was
maybe a small error or whatever uh but
it's indicative of the fact that you
fundamentally are
a bad horrible racist misogynist
whatever person
and
i think i i don't know whether i can lay
it at the feet of the left or sort of
woke ideology overall but it certainly
seems like with the situation with
whoopi goldberg a lot of people on the
right saw this is an opportunity to be
like right let's give them a taste of
their own medicine
if they are going to
demand such what we feel are overblown
responses to some of the things that we
don't think are egregious when the
people on the left decide to make this
much of an error we're going to try and
throw the kitchen sink at it
yeah but it didn't work so what does
that gain you um so i i that's number
one and number two is i think that
i agree with you what you're saying in
terms of tip the iceberg but what i
think the issue is as kovid is receding
as an excuse
for uh cultural and social control and
political control both by media outlets
and governments
they need a new excuse
in order to have you know total
domination over people's lives and it's
going to be really hard to find one
because a pandemic makes sense this is
something that affects literally
everyone this is something where you can
only have quite limited control in terms
of how it spreads it's a virus quite
literally it goes viral
but if you're going to pivot from that
to
kind of white supremacy
first of all that's less tangible second
of all
the number of people who identify as
white supremacist is virtually nil
and it's very hard to
to tell these truckers for example who
were like you know i don't believe in
these mandates well the only reason you
care about that is white supremacy it's
like well the white supremacy is i'm
driving through the snow and putting my
life in danger all the time because this
is the most dangerous job on earth so
it's they don't know where to pivot from
uh you know the last couple of years
where they've had a great excuse to
completely control every aspect of
people's lives so there's a degree of
anxiety that needs to be broadcast and
correct if you're unable to keep that
with one very large warhead you need
multiple smaller ones to try and
contribute to it but which it's but it's
nowhere near as effective i mean it's
one thing to kind of you know new
hiroshima it's nothing to be a sniper
it's just like sure the sniper is going
to make people scared but it's nowhere
near as unconditional surrender dude
i've just thought of something so you
know how a lot of the time people get
one of the concerns that you have for a
more libertarian or conservative type
people is that during a crisis the
government is then going to overstep and
a lot of the rights that they seize from
you during this time of emergency ones
that you don't get back
what it sounds like you're saying here
is that there is an equivalent with the
media that the media raise the water
level of the neuroticism the anxiety the
ambient anxiety that pervades through
everything uh and sort of the volume of
vitriol that is in the press and they
also
aren't keen about correct allowing us
this is such a [ __ ] interesting model
to think about the media are much worse
than the governments and and we know
this because
let's suppose i was a
democratic governor or a labor minister
whatever in the uk
and i looked at the data and i said wait
a minute there's nothing behind this
social distancing this is nonstop like
where's the six feet coming from how the
hell is that going to prevent anything
and okay theoretically you're saying
it's going to prevent it well it's not
working because you know we had social
distinct code would still spread
everywhere
if i said this on television i'd be out
of office
because
immediately every outlet from left to
right would be like uh you know shadow
minister malice doesn't says social
distinct doesn't work he wants us to oh
he clearly wants us to die he's not
following the science this guy's a
lunatic why is he opening his mouth look
at all these people saying this if
social and side note if social this
thing was efficacious why are we
bringing it back and if we're not
bringing it back why do we do to begin
with that's a separate note but i would
not be in a position
as a politician to question this and we
know this because you know people call
gavin newsom who is the governor here of
california who was caught having dinner
while socialistic rules were in effect
and there are many other such cases
where you know politicians were just
basically being hypocrites
they knew but in their defense what were
they supposed to do
they they had no choice but to follow
this drumbeat as you were saying of
ambient anxiety
dude that's such a good
concept to keep in mind
that this is what conservatives get
wrong conservatives are think that the
enemy or
the labor party or the democrats here
and we're going to kick joe biden out of
office or we're going to be jeremy
corbyn blah blah
that that's not the issue when you have
jeremy corbyn is the tail joe biden is
the tail the corporate press are the dog
who are wagging that tail
[ __ ] i'm not going to be able to get
that out of my head but it's you cannot
see it another example i used a couple
years ago was let's suppose i'm a
democratic politician and i think trump
is dividing america i think he's
completely either a racist or he's uh
fuming the fuels of racism to further
his agenda and i think he's an ass and i
think he's an educated and think he's
boorish i think he has no business being
in the white house but i don't think he
should be impeached or removed from
office from a dopey phone call where he
was fishing for something that the
impeachment has no one's been rude from
office before uh this is does not reach
that level
i can't as a democrat go in front of my
constituents who heard four years of
russia russia russia and trump
collusion and keep my seat
i did not have that freedom so it's very
clear
who's in charge of whom
dude
do you follow am i wrong no you're not
and it's it's just when you see
something that ties all of the threads
together that's like a common
a a single concept like that that the
goal of the press is to keep the volume
high that's actually what they're trying
to achieve and it explains why so many
topics recently have been overblown when
you see like why the [ __ ] endless
endless stories in mainstream media
about rogan
about who he's had on the show or about
what he said in the past or about
whatever and then reactions to the
reactions and then has the the white
house said something
all the canadian truckers or just pick
whatever it is because you're right you
know if you've got a huge huge vat of
anxiety to fill and the pandemic starts
to slowly get lifted out of that
so
the question that i have that i always
come back to and it's the one that i
keep on asking you about is
what is the end goal is it just that
greater fear brings greater control
it gives you power it gives you strength
it gives you money and it gives you a
status because now everyone's looking at
me to make decisions uh so that's good
for my ego and my
status and it also
for many of the audience it rationalizes
their um
mental disquiet uh now because they're
they're filling a need as well so
they're not only creating a need they're
also filling a need um among you know
educated urban uh wealthy people who are
kind of disquieted by their nature
do you follow
iela girl on twitter
a-e-l-l-a
a-e-l-l no i never heard her okay so
she's part of i guess like tangentially
on the rationalist community she's
pretty interesting she's written a lot
of blog posts about how to maximize
money on only fans but she's also big
into philosophy and stuff as well she's
quite interesting anyway she she put
this tweet out the other day that i
thought was really cool uh last year my
roommates and i had fun
she's in austin and it says she her
her twitter biography simply has the
word [ __ ] lord
hold on yeah
yeah yeah uh yeah she's interesting man
she's worth a follow um but she put this
tweet up the other day that said last
year my roommates and i had fun gambling
with gamestop one day i woke up and said
you know it's weird i just don't feel
interested in gamestop anymore and my
roommate heard that and immediately sold
right before the crash
i'm sort of having this feeling with
woke stuff there's something like it's
just not interesting anymore i think
part of me believes that big
institutions don't really take it
seriously scott alexander echoed this in
a recent
astral codex 10 blog post and i agree it
feels like i never actually run into
woke people now it's just not trendy and
this i don't know how true this is
because i've never really seen it other
than on the internet so you know the
libs of
type videos that get captured and then
put online or a matt walsh
ben shapiro reaction video like i'll see
those so that was only my only ever
introduction to it
but i think that there's definitely
something to be said for
endless
satire
and mocking being really really
effective as a tool to make something so
contaminated and toxic to be associated
with
that people no longer want to do it
because you can try and litigate
something out of existence but it's
really hard to do that you know to
somehow try and top down it but if you
make it so uncool to be associated with
just through like effective satire and
mockery
people are just going to drop it like a
hot stone they don't want to be
associated with something that lowers
their status
well it's also kind of being a tryhard
right so it's whether it's
a bodybuilder right or someone who has a
lot of makeup but also a full beard
and when you glance at this person
rightly or wrongly a lot of people like
you are spending a lot of time on your
appearance
to create a reaction on site when people
see you and i don't care what it is but
i'm not interested in learning more now
this is a prejudice that is incorrect
there's lots of people in both of those
groups i mentioned who are quality
people that you would learn a lot from
but when you are presenting yourself in
a certain specific way that takes a lot
of work and is several standard
integrations away from what is
considered you know acceptable or normal
whatever bad word you want to use
this is going to make people simply
like okay here we go right before they
meet you um and i disagree a little bit
because
corporate america is where things go to
die
uh you know they appropriate things from
the fringes they swallow them and then
excrete them in a matter that's
palatable to the masses so we've got a
ways to go before this kind of is
gets through the corporate kind of
digestive system
um
and you know the thing that people
no one has as much content for corporate
america as i do but what people need to
appreciate is
they're often very bandwagon
these are not very bright like someone
will read an article in
bloomberg or fortune some
60 year old exec about oh this company
got a lot of free publicity from a viral
video okay we need to make a viral video
now it's like what it was was that and
it's like well i read this article or
like we need to have a blog this was a
thing or we should have a twitter now
now if you sat him down
and said
hold on we make nails
for
kind of industrial concerns why do we
need a twitter um
why do we need a twitter did you not see
this article from fortune it says this
company's you know profits increased by
ten percent thanks to social media what
are you an idiot so i remember very much
that
and this is obviously a poor example but
it was a telling one trump show the
apprentice
and there was some detergent commercial
detergent let's i don't even remember
what it was let's say tied or whatever
and the task for both teams was
create a viral video
and perez hilton was the judge right the
blogger perez hilton
and one team brought in a bunch of
little people and like the little
persons in the washing machine and
they're running around and i don't
remember what the other team did but it
was something silly and goofy and perez
is like
these are great like i would share this
with my friend like they made a viral
video and then trump who's the host sat
down with the execs and they were livid
they're like this is a family
product
and you're making like you're being
silly
both of these are completely
unacceptable so what he wanted
was like a commercial
of mom using the detergent and now the
detergent cleans the clothes and for
some oblivious reason everyone is
sharing this
and he had no concept of what a viral
video was so they'll they'll be for this
woke stuff
but these people are often effectively
mindless they'll just see some article
and be like oh okay diversity and
inclusion you know helps company gain
market share okay we need that
and what that means is we're going to
hire a black lady
but i mean they're they're
dumb and beyond dumb
and that's why i'm so confident that the
good guys are going to win
half of it is probably
forward-thinking aggressive growth
motive but maybe even more than that to
me feels like fear you know of the
companies that have done this it's a
fear of what happens if you don't but
not right most companies were posting
the black square because if you didn't
the repercussions were grave look look
at crossfit
yep [ __ ] man i had so i had ben bergeron
on who is the
coach of matt fraser and catching
david's daughter for a good period of
time two of the fittest athletes on the
planet he owns comp train and crossfit
new england in boston and i had him on
and i was asking about the recent
cancellations that have occurred so greg
glassman who was the founder he tweeted
some stuff that was inappropriate last
uh two years ago now
instantly gone a big bunch of people
went with him but there was one guy left
dave castro director of the crossfit
games the guy that writes the workouts
for the open so arguably the most
influential and important person in all
of crossfit hq he's got he used to be a
navy seal very no [ __ ] very straight
down the line kind of
puts some people off but
a real character right like a not the
same as this but he he is a figurehead
in the same way that perhaps an elon
musk would be a figurehead right that he
is he adds to the brand with the way
that uh he puts himself across
and sure enough he
three weeks ago posts on instagram that
he's been notified that his services are
no longer needed but he found out
essentially through a news article
and that the guy that had taken over
greg glassman the original owner's role
this eric rosa dude had spoken to him
and said yeah we uh we sort of don't
need you anymore uh even though this guy
is
very very very legit probably one of the
best programmers on the planet
and the reason i think he went is he was
the last vestige of
the old guard the final people that were
in this company and he's a risk to have
somebody like that now within a company
who will speak their mind who doesn't
really care about adhering to whatever
the new doctrine and the new ideology is
having that person is rolling the dice
every time that you let them say
something on a microphone yeah oh yeah
for sure
uh and so it's um
and there's many cases like that uh and
that's the other thing i i worked at um
goldman sachs and jp morgan
the
you know there was this kind of myth or
maybe it was the facts that you back in
the day you were a company man you
worked for a company they took care of
you and and you know you would save them
with a life they'll lack the amount of
loyalty these firms expect
and the zero loyalty they have in return
the fact that he had to find this out
from an article instead of him being
given a big celebratory
safe public space saving like you know
what i'm moving on to form my own
venture thank you crossfit thank you for
helping us you know what i mean these
are really
nasty uh despicable reprehensible people
who will
sell you genocide with a smile on their
face because this ties exactly back to
these are the people who are selling
missiles and tanks in order to kill
children overseas i remember i bring
this example all the time because this
to me was the most disturbing example of
corporate sociopathy
during the iraq war i believe this was
on cnn there was some executive
um talking about you know the upcoming
campaign against uh baghdad and they
were talking about the shock and awe
attack that was going to be imminent and
he said if you have to ask it's not
shock and awe and it's like
wait you're you're presenting this like
if you have to ask if this is the
biggest bouquet you've ever seen
you know what i mean it's like shocking
means an entire city population i'm sure
many of whom were loyal to saddam or bad
people i'm sure many of whom had blood
on their hands but also
thousands if not tens of thousands of
children tens of thousands of innocent
people if they're not terrorized then we
haven't done our job and he had this big
smile on his face and you knew there was
this big white board and he had sat down
the department of defense and talked
about how awesome it's going to be that
for 24 hours it would be stronger than
the sun and everyone there would be so
terrified they'd be literally crapping
their pants and begging for surrender
and it's like you are literally
a demon
you know selling death and destruction
and with a smile on your face and have
no concept of anything remotely close to
humanity
it's crazy that these people get into
positions of power
it's not crazy because it's like it's
the same way that
you know uh
child predators are gonna go where the
children are
they're going to be drawn
to where their talents
are of use how much of it do you think
is innate and how much is a feedback
mechanism from the position that they
need to be in and the things they need
to do once they get there
oh that's a great question i don't know
i could i could give an answer but it
would be completely spread out yeah yeah
yeah um melissa chen tweeted the other
day about how china is great china's
mandatory app for health monitoring do
you see this
no oh bro uh china is requiring a
mandatory health app that is ostensibly
for health monitoring for all beijing
olympics participants media and
government officials as you'd expect it
turns out to be spyware that records
everything said have fun at beijing 2020
and she's quote tweeting a guy who is a
programmer saying after reverse
engineering all of the beijing 2020 app
for ios and android i can definitively
say all olympian audio is being
collected analyzed and saved on chinese
servers using tech from usa blacklisted
ai firm
ifly tech
well they should be looking at like all
sorts of really bad porn so that all
those chinese sensors send
i'm going to see all this iconography
or just start googling
uh um
june 4th 1989. what's up
cn man square
right what
i don't know man just all of this stuff
this seems to you know that's what i
would do i'd wear tiana those tank man
t-shirts
just see what i'm gonna do about it yeah
yeah
i'm trying to marry across stuff that
like that is you know because presumably
those apps are probably going to be able
to hold on to your phone even after
you've deleted it of course they'll be
sure they're going to clone it yes get a
image of it rather yep and you'll then
if you message somebody else perhaps i
don't know i'm not sure how secure
android and ios can be but not
sufficiently secure to avoid being a
spyware app for a health monitoring
thing
there's no way they're not going to get
all your contacts immediately
that is a real scary
new story
meanwhile
the press is focusing on
whether
joe rogan's last podcast had the right
balance on it or whether stuff that he
said 12 years ago really matters like
the press also doesn't like telling
stories
where they can't paint themselves as
victorious
so there's a guy here in austin named
cody wilson and he's behind 3d printing
guns so how it works is you have a 3d
printer in your house and you hit print
and a certain amount of time later you
have a gun that's unregistered and
untraceable now they've tried to pass
laws around this but the laws have no
efficacy because he's not selling guns
he's selling files and a 3d you're going
to ban 3d printing that's not going to
happen either so this is something
that's not given because organization
called defense distributed this is
something that's not given wide parlance
because the conclusion is
there's nothing we can do about this and
that makes them look very very bad
because what they're selling is
at
corporate media outlets will present a
problem and in the next paragraph
they'll present the best solution which
is a right away
which is them or someone who's you know
in power uh in part thanks to them so
right away me if i'm going to be a
well-read person i'm going to cure a
problem and i'm going to advocate for
this solution uh with all my force with
articles like this now he's gotten some
coverage but it's nowhere near as big as
you would otherwise expect
there's no solution so they what they
try to do is they try to say well if a
gun
if this is like 15 of a gun that's
legally
counted as a gun he's like okay here's
the file for 85 percent of a gun so
there's no way that they can kind of
legislate around this even
definitionally um and again this is not
something because again if sorry keep
saying that if you watch cnn
i can't have a five-minute segment where
this is something so complicated with no
resolution without the viewer leaving
like okay i know what to think now
dude i saw a story the other day of a
guy who had worked out how to 3d print a
3d printer
oh
far too clever way way way too clever
that guy needs to be locked up
what are you drinking how big is that
arizona it's my macros
so this is for megan eric this is from
megan mccain arizona baby for the people
who've never been out drinking with
michael mallis and growing soft drinks
you are one of the only people i know
that chooses to rip the ring pull off
the top yep there it is that way i know
it's my bottle
who else is in the room with you
like if i'm at a party and everyone has
a beer
they're not at a party
well this is just a throwback to college
it's just part of that you were getting
accused not long ago of the reason that
your uh headphones were tangled was
because you were
just a straight up chaos merchant and
yeah i feel like i feel like this just
plays into that how is this chaos it's
it's order i know which one's mine
i'm unsure but yeah the guy could uh 3d
print a 3d printer which is pretty
concerning but so the main thing that
i've taken away
from today
is that
the press themselves are an entity with
their own agenda which
the
can interrupt you yeah not a bias an
agenda
everyone knew that they had a bias
that's inevitable we're gonna have a
perspective yes that they have an agenda
what's the difference
because the bias is okay i'm going to
look at this story from a
labor point of view or liberal point of
view conservative or a tory point of
view as opposed to
i am writing this story because i want
people to feel a certain way my goal
isn't to inform my goal goal is to
manipulate my goal is to affect social
change
that's scary
why
because they influence the opinions of
so many
people sure but
those people are it's one mind in many
persons
yes but it is a
very large swath of the population i i
keep on i keep on thinking about this
the more that
i dig into whatever you want to call it
the heterodox sphere of sense making or
whatever
the less that you can see how norm
normal people view the media that they
consume you know vast majority of people
probably the first time they ever heard
of joe rogan was when the spotify deal
went through and then the next time
might have been this week
you think okay next time no no it was
the spotify deal then joe rogan's
irrelevant because of the spotify deal
because they try to sing that song for a
while remember that no one cares what he
thinks anymore and then it was joe
rogan's is an existential threat to
america because he doesn't want people
to get vaccinated which he never said
rudy giuliani was on the foxes the
masked singer did you see this
no
unmasking of rudy giuliani on fox's the
masked singer prompts judges ken jong
and robin thicke to walk off in protest
rudy giuliani was unmasked as an exiting
costume contender
in last week's taping of the first
season seven episode of fox's popular
primetime show the masked singer the
show is known for its jaw-dropping
surprises when celebrity contestants
shed their headpieces after they were
eliminated the reaction to giuliani was
perhaps the most polarizing the show has
seen since 2020 the masked singer
yeah the mask singer was another
republican politician sarah palin was
unveiled as the bear i'm glad that we've
got clarity on what character it was
that she uh she decided i think she did
baby got back
i'm pretty sure
so it wasn't just that it was sarah
palin who i'm sure has a perfectly fine
sitting voice i wouldn't put that past
her but i think yeah it was baby got
back
i love how so this is from deadline.com
deadline.com uh mentioned we aren't
revealing which costume rudy wore or
what his swan song was his exit won't
won't air until next month so he can
still revel in his reveal the theme of
the new season is the good the bad and
the cuddly your political affiliation
determines which category giuliani fits
into
deadline here's the watch young and
thick exited they eventually returned
fellow judges jenny mccarthy and nicole
scherzinger remained on stage they
banted with giuliani a controversial
figure for blah blah blah blah fox did
not comment
uh
yeah rudy giuliani on i mean that's from
white house to shite house isn't it
well i mean he's been
uh
really
lost a lot of credibility among
republicans for how he handled
um
the trump election in 2020. uh he kind
of made a big ass of himself and i know
there was one press conference where his
hair dye started leaking down his face
was that the same one where he booked it
outside of like an air conditioning
factory did you see that
no
oh dude
this is the
so good so i can't remember he he booked
it for a particular location let's say
um
the palm or west palm something or
whatever and it turns out that the
location that they booked
was the
some air conditioning factory
so all of the press had turned up and it
wasn't at some grand hotel to give this
big reveal about some important [ __ ]
they were just stood outside of like
some middle america [ __ ] workplace
and they just decided to go ahead with
it rather than trying to change it and
pivot it to like havana club west or
whatever they went to havana club air
conditioning creators
um
so yeah it was a how would you say
catalog of errors uh culminating in him
now being on the master center
which is important yeah and he's really
old at this point isn't he like almost
80 if not 80. they used that photo of
him with the the head eye
uh
falling down the side of his face as
well which does look pretty scary
he's 77 yeah he's so he's older than
biden
is he [ __ ] hell yeah biden is i think
76.
he's 77 biden is no he's biden 79 i
apologize but i mean they're comparable
there
how was the night that i missed at the
tesla factory because we haven't we
haven't got to speak about this oh god
talk about imposter syndrome
you know i'm there with midnight with
jordan peterson elon musk and joe rogan
michaela was there of course who i'm
pals with um
and if you had told this the fact is
gigantic i've never been a factory that
big giga factory right
is that what's called that i don't know
it's like tesla drive or something but
if you had told me that there was
because it's very brightly lit
right and austin is not bright at night
because there's not a lot of street
lights like back in new york obviously
um
and i'm sure newcastle it might be the
same way if they're if you there and
there's people there like midnight like
who are like what's going on over there
and if you had told me
that um
like one of these rooms had a ufo that
they were reverse engineering it very
much felt like independence day when
they were doing that
and i was like can i who can i look at
who can i talk to i was very
um
this is it was kind of almost like being
like north korea like when you're in
north korea uh you're there you're like
this is not my place like i don't belong
here so you really gotta
be on guard about what you say look at
or do and make eye contact the whole
time so when i was there even though i'd
been invited and cleared i was still
like all right like am i allowed into
this truck
can i take a picture of this like i was
just so scared
fun though
uh i don't know if that would be the
word it would my mind awe-inspiring
why not fun nervousness
yeah i just i couldn't let my guard down
did you get to meet elon because you
were there when he was recording his
babylon bee thing but yeah i didn't get
to talk to him um we all hung out after
i didn't want to be that guy
um
uh
yeah you know i i just spent time
talking to the petersons and joe cool
there was a story that i read the other
day about a spacex rocket on a collision
course with the moon after spending
almost seven years hurtling through
space so the booster got launched in
2015 it was doing some [ __ ] and then uh
it ended up
in a very chaotic orbit and uh
eventually it's going to
hit the moon and it's not going to be a
big deal but uh space fanatics look
forward to seeing what lessons can come
from it went through its
lagrange point a gravity neutral
position four times further than the
moon and in direct line with the sun and
then the rocking second stage is gonna
end up falling into it so elon is uh
also getting rid of his rockets by
hitting them into the moon
okay cool the uh america the earth's
garbage pit
the moon yeah the earth's garbage pit uh
what have you got coming up how's
everything else with you
uh i'm writing about um the holodemour
now so that's
uh not very fun
that's when stalin starved millions of
ukrainians um and and it was the most
disturbing part is if they ransacked
your house
and you didn't have any grain
that's how they knew you were hiding it
right that's the logic so you better
freaking find it so they go search your
house during the day
search it again at night
if they would just
burn people's houses down throw them in
the street including whole families
naked
in the middle of winter
break people's hands and doorknob indoor
jams things like that
and the thing is if you weren't starving
your own body betrayed you because they
could look at you and see oh you have
food and you better [ __ ] hand it over
so this was and it was covered up by the
western journalists at the time who said
there's no feminine this is just
anti-russia propaganda so going through
that writing about it for the next book
is uh uh it's this is not a particularly
insightful thing to say but when you
hear about you know children
being starved to death intentionally it
doesn't number on you do you find it
working i was gonna say is it
emotionally draining to write that stuff
yeah especially because you know many of
the people who covered this up were
never held accountable to this day
and also the fact that this is in public
knowledge the fact that you were like
what's that i mean this is a
complete atrocity crime against humanity
um
just awful awful thing
and uh
it's just
it's also it's heartening
to know that this is going to be widely
read
and that i get to kind of uh you know
advocate for these people and and give
them their testimony this is where i'm
from so it kind of knowing this is in my
dna
also kind of hits a little close to home
but it's it's rough
i learned about uh pol pot had a
oh yeah he had a a
series of situations where anybody who
wore glasses
was immediately killed
because people that wore glasses were
part of the intellectual bourgeoisie
or or didn't have callouses on their
hands i think was another one
they killed a quarter of the population
like less than a decade
[ __ ] hellman
and that's so recent it's just you know
when you see all of this stuff pieced
together and the fact that you've got
yes the 70s the assistant this isn't
like 500 years ago this is the 70s
why is it do you think that we've
forgotten just how brutal people can be
is it just that
memories are short do we believe or has
the world believed at large that we've
transcended the nasty parts of our
nature because we've become so
enlightened with technology and
convenience and stuff
because what's the narrative with pol
pot
there's the media can't tell you
anything
we didn't do anything about it i don't
know that we could have done anything
about it
um so when there's no
story corporate america likes to have a
story everything's gonna be fine you're
safe just listen to us
and here's a example where that was not
the case that it's like well like the
korean war we talk about world war ii
we talk about the vietnam war the korean
war was a draw so no one talks about it
because there's no story there even
though the entire korean peninsula was
devastated the korean people were just
decimated both north and south but
there's no narrative
but what about again what media wants to
sell a story they don't want to sell
information
what about the people that just exist
normal day-to-day people i think like
if you were to suggest to them that this
is something that could happen again
most people would say no no no of course
not we're past that now
or no it's also that the russians are
russians have always been treated as
basically martians
um with some good reason i think the
russian psyche is very different from
the western psyche um but also it's it's
hard because there was no photographs
so it's one thing when you see it
it's another thing to read about it if i
tell you a sentence
i saw a pile of starving a kid starved
to death
okay you can read that sentence it's
tough if i show you a picture of me
standing in front of this
this is a whole other situation
michael miles ladies and gentlemen
people want to keep up to date with what
you're doing where should they go
to the psychiatrist
see you soon man
what's happening people thank you very
much for tuning in if you enjoyed that
episode then press here for a selection
of the best clips from the podcast over
the last few weeks and don't forget to
subscribe
peace